Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors. Welcome to another episode of Connors Clinic Live.
Today's episode is going to be a good friend of mine, Dr. Brady Weirich. Dr. Brady practices out in Idaho.
I've known him for many, many years. In his practice, really concentrates on stem cells and using stem cells to heal all sorts of things.
The injury shoulder injuries, hip injuries. I know you're going to love this video. He gives a little practical advice on what to do and helping with the aging process that we all go through.
As always, don't forget to hit the like button of the video. And if you're on YouTube, make sure you subscribe and hit that little alarm notification so that you don't miss any new episodes.
Join me with Dr. Brady Weirich. Okay, welcome everybody. My guest today is Dr. Brady Weirich, and he practices in Idaho Falls way out of the West Coast for me in Minnesota.
So we're going to jump right into it. Brady, you graduate as a chiropractor. When was that?
Oh, geez, 2006. I graduated from Texas chiropractic college. Okay. And then what brought you to Idaho? Fishing. Fishing. Well, actually, I grew up about three hours south of where I am now. I mean, Idaho Falls, Idaho. I grew up in a small town just outside of Salt Lake City.
Well, it's not so small anymore. But when I went to chiropractor, when I was doing my undergrad, I was actually a fly fishing guide.
Well, I would take people down the river of the green river, the flaming orge in the Wyoming Colorado Utah border. There's a beautiful river there. And I would take them down the river that we would fish blah, blah, blah.
When I went to chiropractic school, my boat was about the only thing I didn't sell. And so when I came to priorities straight at least, when I came time to figure out where I wanted to practice, the logic was, you know, I can, I can go back to Ogden and I can have, you know, all these family and friends ready to see me.
But it's going to take me about four hours to get my boat in the water. Sure. I can go to Idaho Falls, establish my own practice, establish my own people and be 20 to 30 minutes from having my boat in the water. And here we are, 13 years later, you can see which decision won.
Well, that's great. Well, you've started off practicing as a chiropractor, but you very quickly got into functional medicine, functional neurology, which is a whole field itself. Tell us a little bit about that.
Sure. So I really never actually practice as just a chiropractor. It was never, and I mean, absolutely no insult when I say it this way, but I was never one of those find a bump smash it down guys.
And I do clearly acknowledge that the chiropractic profession has done a tremendous amount for health, for health care for individuals.
But that was never really my gig. My first semester at chiropractic school, they had a party for all the new students where they're introducing all of the clubs. And I found this neurology club.
And the things that they were talking about that this neurology club explaining how the nerves work and how the body control or the nerves control the body and how you could affect, have an effect on a nerve by firing a nerve. It all just resonated with me. It all, it sounded awesome.
And so I started studying neurology as a chiropractic student. So when I graduated from chiropractic college, I had, I had been through enough core extra coursework that I could sit and take the neurology diplomate exam. So
Well, for our listeners who don't understand what that is functional neurology was really put on the back by Dr. Karek, there's medical doctors and neurologists that go through that course because it's so extensive.
It is literally the elite of the elite of both medical and chiropractic professions that graduate from care. It's
a diplomat program. So hats off to you there. Thanks, man. I appreciate that.
And now you're, you're doing some, you're doing, you practice functional neurology for a period of time. And now you've branched off into doing some other work that's even more adept. Is that right.
And that's, that's true.
About
I'm going to say about three years ago, one of our colleagues started bothering me about, or not bothering me.
Pestry, I don't know how to cope with you nudging me in the direction of this whole regenerative medicine thing.
And at the time, it was just stem cells. He started talking about stem cells. I'm like, what, what are you talking about? What in the world is a stem cell?
I'd remember, I remember talking about them in chiropractic school, but I really just didn't have a clue. So I started looking into it a little bit deeper.
And the more I dug, the more it made sense to me, these are the benefit of it.
It's not the benefit of it. I thought it was doing for people, you know, throughout my career, I've helped a tremendous amount of people with some crazy, you know, things that no one else could help with.
But at the end of the day, when it came to osteoarthritic joints and, you know, these bone on bone arthritis cases, they really only had one option.
And that was to refer them to a reply.
But what really got me got me excited about this is, well, you could take one of those bone on bone cases.
Give them one injection and put off having to have surgery for possibly even ever. Yeah.
My dad was, I'm not going to call him my guinea pig because I had to commit to this before I could actually do it because you have to, you know, being, being a chiropractor, I can't put needles in people. I can't prescribe anything.
So I had to put the pieces in place so that I could hire nurse practitioners to do the, to do that portion before me. So there really was no, hey, I'm going to test this other than just going full throttle.
My dad was the very first person that we injected and that was, we're going on about 19 months ago. And at the time of his injection, both of his knees were scheduled for replacement surgery.
And he's completely avoided pain road. It's just two weekends ago. He wrote his bicycle 27 miles in Sun Valley. I mean, it's just, it's crazy.
And that was just my dad. And now we're going to all these other people that are coming back saying, holy cow, I can't believe this. Like, you know, just recently, I posted about a, a gal that was 85 years old.
And her doctor basically said, if you want out of this back pain, then you're going to have to have this extensive back surgery. And at 85 years old, you and I both know how well that turns out.
Right. That's not good.
And now she's back going, I'm, you know, 50% better. And I'm able to do these particular activities. But the more you dig in this stuff, Kevin, the more it just, it blows my mind.
Because now we've gone from stem cells to these things called exosomes, which are the, the chemical secretions that chem cells stem cells released to do their job and readily cross the blood brain barrier.
Wow.
So now we're seeing people that come in and they're saying the first thing that they notice is that their brain fog is starting to clear up their energy started to lived. And so we're having
neurological and systemic effects just through injections.
Yeah. I'm just really interested to see what kind of results you get with people with early onset dementia and what that's going to do for them. And that could push Alzheimer's.
My mother died with full blown Alzheimer's right at a big part of what pushed her into the dementia realm was the was her knee replacement surgery that she had.
She had a lot of problems with it. She was supposed to get both these down. She refused to get the second knee done. And that was a couple years before her dementia really unset.
So that was before stem cells existed. The knowledge of this existed. I wish we could go back in time to change things. I don't know what the outcome would be. I think it would be a lot more positive than it was.
For sure. You know, we're still a long ways off from knowing exactly, but we're seeing very, very promising things. And I think it's important to that we know that there's a lot of.
Miss what's the word I'm looking for misconceptions about stem cell therapy. There's a lot of people that still hang on to this crazy idea that we're using like embryonic cells or cells that are coming from a board fetal tissue.
Well, no, but that that was been proven a couple of years ago that I know people. I get flack for that here still. Yeah, it's just not happening. It's not true. These come from donated umbilical cords that are tissue that unfortunately in this country 97% of the time this tissue just gets discarded and thrown away. Yeah, the entire stem cell industry is operating off a 3% of the people who will actually donate their cell donate their cords. Right.
Yeah, it's everybody thinks of that if they are old enough think of the bush era where argument about using fetal tissue. Well, it's been long proven that fetal stem cells don't work the way anything else the way stem cells you want them to work. So nobody's using that.
So great. And you're having great success with it. You've been doing this for three years. No, you said. No, we've only actually been doing it for about 18 months, but it took me that long to get enough confidence of information and and to get the pieces put together so we could do it.
Well, you're wise person, not just jumping into something. So, right. And you had a very, very healthy, successful practice. I know that of you, prior to that, you taught functional neurology to doctors. Are you still doing any teaching?
I don't do it for functional neurology. I don't do it for other doctors at this point, but we do a lot of education for our patients.
We still do a lot of functional medicine stuff because, but frankly, you know, the way I put it to people is this. If we're going to help you grow new cartilage, your body needs the building blocks to make those cartilage, yeah, you're that cartilage. So do you want your new car, do you want your new meniscus to be made out of free dose and coke, or do you want it to be made out of real food.
And so we still do quite a bit of educating as far as, hey, this is actually how you should eat and what actually is healthy versus the standard American garbage that's out there now.
Right. So is it mainly need a stem cell work that you're doing or is could you do hips, ankles, any degenerative joint, any degenerative joint.
These and shoulders are the easiest because they're the big juicy encapsulated joints that it's pretty easy to get into that joint capsule.
We still do needs. We still do spines. We still do next, but knees and shoulders are number one and number two.
Okay. Well, well, great. Then what are some other major things that you focus on in your practice? You mentioned diet.
You do a lot of nutritional pieces with these patients too. Yeah, we sure do. We have in fact, if you, if you follow me on social media, you'll see the recently we've been doing something called foodie Friday, which is where we, my wife and I actually post the recipes that we use in our day to day.
And then we have a detox procedure that we developed with US enzymes. We put that together. We have a webinar that's associated with that.
So a diet's a big chunk of it, but here is like the, I'm a daily in the office. It is mainly focused on regenerative medicine.
Well, let's plug your website here. This is your, it's odd for it at your Facebook page too.
So I am region.com is my web is the website.
But if you Facebook is just Dr. Brady Wyric and that's WIR ICK.
So you're it's about all about regenerative medicine. That's a very hot topic. A lot of education on regenerative medicine in the last 10 years.
It's really growing because the practice of medicine tends to be just trying to patch up disease.
And you know, decrease the person's symptoms around a disease process, not really changing a person's body,
or heal from the disease. And more and more people are becoming wise to that.
You know, that's why doctors like you and I are, you know, practices are exploding.
And people are starting to take them. I'm older than you and I remember when I graduated having to educate people.
The difficulty was so high because there was no internet.
There was no other forms of education for people. Now people can Google this information, websites like yours.
They could get a lot of information from take back to their doctors to start doing some things on their own.
And it can be really impressive. Now there's not a lot of doctors doing stem cells like you.
You're kind of a unicorn out there, aren't you?
Unicorn renegade just depends on how you want to look at it.
It is a growing field. And there's stem cell therapy has been happening for about since about 2006.
There were groups of doctors that started using your own stem cells to do regenerative medicine.
And so they would take them, they'd actually do a, they'd drill into your hip and take your bone marrow and culture your own stem cells from there.
And it works. It's a great therapy. But that's first generation biologics.
Now we're in the second and third generation where we now know.
And we have the ability to take those, the umbilical cord cells, which are younger or more potent.
They divide about four times as fast. They're just flat out more effective.
They are an off the shelf product. So what I mean by that is when we have an injection day, like we have an injection day coming up here in two days.
Our prior stem cells are right now sitting in a cryotang that are sitting on liquid night, they're sitting in liquid nitrogen ready for us to use.
So there's more and more doctors that are getting on board with us and seeing some growth from stem cell therapy.
There's a whole bunch of doctors that are sitting back hanging on to those old ways of using your own stem cells and taking shots at those of us who are unicorns and pushing.
The envelope a little bit more. So there is growth in the industry for sure.
And it's just, you know, it's only a matter of time before it's more and more mainstream.
You know, Joe Rogan, I think we all need to thank Joe Rogan. He had Mel Gibson on his podcast and that really.
He was on there talking about stem cell therapy and using a bill of cord stem cells and what he saw from that one his dad saw from it's really just it's becoming more and more prevalent.
Yeah, we'll have to look at that too.
I bet with your kind of service people fly in from all over to it because it's not something you have to do over and over and over again, necessarily.
Are there second injections that you would do down the line?
We have done that in the past for people who just flat out wanted them.
It's not a long time. It's not necessary. We've had people fly from parts of Canada that I didn't know they drove from parts of Canada that I didn't even know existed.
We've had people fly in here. I don't fall. We've had them fly their private jets in here. It's been it's been a very interesting.
Yeah, interesting way of practice.
The interesting thing is it's so much, you know, it's not a procedure where you are laid up for a couple of days or anything like that.
And so there's so less invasive this is really zero risk and it's so much less expensive.
There's no reason why you do a hip or knee or shoulder replacement before you try stem cells.
If the insurance companies had any sense whatsoever.
This is why you have to do this before we're going to let you have surgery.
If we're talking about just a knee joint, for example, you talk about less invasive.
I need joints, two needles.
One, as an IV to take your blood because we do use your own PRP or plasma.
So we'll take your blood, we'll spin that down, we'll combine that with the stem cells and the second needle goes right into the knee joint and you're driving home and your daily activities of daily living aren't very restrictive at all.
That is insane. It's so cool seeing, you know, cutting edge therapies, cutting edge technique that is helping people that isn't based upon, you know, what the, oh my, the insurance dollar pharmaceutical company is personality for people.
So appreciate your work.
We'll get details on your information and contact information up when we do the ads on this too.
I would like to have you back on. I know you wanted to talk about EFFs. I'd like to have you back on if we could.
Anytime.
And record another episode.
Let's get one more plug for your website.
Awesome.
So again, it's I am regen.com.
There you'll find a bunch of information on stem cells and what Dr. Brady where it does and how you get in touch with him.
Thank you, Brady. Dr. Brady, we're in Idaho Falls. It is a pleasure having you on here.
Absolute pleasure, my friend.
All right. Bye-bye.